all right jillian
hi jillian welcome back so so you were
actually here how long ago
i think it was like four or five months
ago it was kind of over the summer
or maybe the toe ends yeah it feels like
it was longer but i didn't even
recognize you when you showed up
you look so different so different yeah
things have only kind of gotten worse um
i've lost probably more than 100 pounds
you lost 100 pounds yeah wow
and you're using crystal meth still
crystal meth yeah
what's what's been going on since since
i saw you left um
you know i talked about how i've never
been in an abusive relationship
i found myself back with an ex that i
never thought would
lay a hand on me and he beat the living
dog [ __ ] out of me
a couple times we went our separate ways
due to the breakup i went harder into my
addiction
not caring about myself just wanting to
numb
my pain not wanting to feel anything
but just wanting that high that fix that
that something would just take me out of
myself
you know and um and that's what i've
done since then
it's you know i went harder into my
hustle
like just it's you know it almost feels
like
i i feel like i've slept with almost
every single person in long beach
or down here in la i feel like
everywhere i turn
i'm running into into the same
[ __ ] that i i've
had run in with that i've slept with and
it's it's like i'm repeating the same
day over and over and over with this
the same people but different stories
it's it's
it's almost like sometimes i think i'm
getting punked like like i'm
living some kind of alternate like it
doesn't make sense to me like it makes
me crazy
to think i see these same people over
and over and over
and then they tell me they don't know me
and the next time i see them they're
driving a cop car
and i don't understand it like i try to
figure out like why
like why is this happening like why is
you know but like people say you're just
being paranoid i know it's
just not me being paranoid um
regardless what city i go to i come down
i'm trying to stay down here more
because my my workers trying to get me
housing
um so even if i shoot down the long
beach or i shoot down to wilmington if i
shoot down to as far as san bernardino
people the same people know where i'm at
regardless no matter where i go
the same people are always there so not
only am i dealing with
my using and my addiction i'm dealing
with people that
won't leave me alone and i keep it to
myself or
i'll share with people i trust and they
try to tell me it's all in my mind and
i don't feel like it's all in my mind
where are you staying now
um right now or do you sleep on meth you
don't really sleep much
well um probably the first time in like
months i probably got over 24 hours of
sleep i just slept and i slept and i
slept
i met someone yeah he let me just sleep
we both slept
that's all we did was just sleep and
rest and
and like today that's all i've been
trying to do is just trying to hope to
meet someone that
i could just rest and like be off the
streets like get tired
it makes me crazy how many days have you
been up
in a row i don't know i mean i'll i'll
nap on the bus
and up on the train um
i kind of i don't really keep track
it's kind of hard to keep track all i
think about
now like today has been stay hydrated
stay hydrated
i haven't even really got high like
getting high is like the last thing in
my mind
and everyone just sees me as some dope
being [ __ ] and i got my
money hungry oh
but i'm not at this point i'm about my
survival i'm about trying to
try to find almost like a way out but
it's like i know the way out but it's
like i'm trying to prove a point
it's like i'm trying to prove something
and i don't know what that
it's almost like everyone expects me to
quit and everyone expects me that
she's she's just a dumb [ __ ] let's see
how much we could just fool her
are you in contact with your family my
mom
my mom tells me when i call her how much
my oldest
izzy is hurting how sad
she is when i do talk to my oldest she
tells me she's afraid i'm going to drive
a
die of a drug overdose and when i do
speak to her
i tell her i'm not worried about that
i'm more worried i'm going to die over
the lifestyle
the lifestyle will kill me before the
drugs ever do
you know say the lifestyle you mean just
the people that you're
[ __ ] with all these all these people
from different
areas crows cities eventually they all
start talking
you know what i mean and it's um it's
not very smart
on my part you know because i piss off
the wrong person
not meaning to you know where they feel
like
unjust or they feel like i [ __ ] them
over or took
advantage but really these guys are
doing the same thing
but it's almost like it's okay but if a
[ __ ] does it
it's not okay what just keeps you from
from just quitting and
walking away and getting your life
together
sometimes i don't i don't know if there
for me if there is a way out because
i'll go to a program i'll go to detox
i'll clean myself
up i'll do all the right things for a
couple months or almost a year
and i'll go right back to it and i'm
convinced i will go right back to it
again
so to do a rehab just seems like a waste
of time no it's
it's i think it's fear that i'm not
going to stay
it's fear that i'm just going to go back
and [ __ ] up again that's my fears i'm
going to go back again
and do it again what do you think drives
you to go back and
relapse um
when i start feeding when i um
start crying because i i'm very
emotional i'm very
so involved in my feelings that when i'm
feeling something so deeply
it could be some something so small as a
girl saying no
i can't sell you this dollar soda at
mcdonald's for a dollar only because you
don't have nine cents
i will cry over that i'll get really
angry
because i feel like if it was me and
someone needed something
to drink how can you turn away someone
who needs it who needs a drink
i don't understand but that could just
like i don't know like
i've i've experienced things that brings
me back to my childhood of being bullied
and being made fun of and like it kills
me it like
kills me like the way people treat me
and
the fact that i allow it that i know
there's a way out but i
i'm still playing it out here
it's like i hate myself for it
and the shame makes you stay out here
stay out here and
staying out here gives you more shame
and it's endless cycle
you know i've met good people on the way
and i feel like everyone i've come
across
whether big or small insignificant or
make a significant impact in my life
i always take those relationships with
me no matter what
because each person teaches me something
it's made me take a look at myself you
know like i haven't always been like
the greatest person i've been mean and
like
but i know that's not really me me
treating people like [ __ ] and
is you know it's almost like it becomes
like
second nature being on the streets after
a while it's like you lose who you are
as a person
you know and i i feel like i'm
spiritually
spiritually emotionally dead inside
don't even know who i am anymore
the street life and the uh the drugs
just change your personality
right you don't know who to trust you
seeing the person you're talking to that
you can fight in
your friend but really nobody out here
is your friend
no one out here cares do you feel like
you have any friends
um yeah i my friends in recovery
the people that have been behind me for
many many many
years that are waiting for me to just
get it
to [ __ ] come back to the rooms and
surrender
but it's like i'm so proud i have so
much pride and ego that
it's like i won't let myself i don't
know i don't know
what do you do you still have hope of
getting your life together
i know i'm at the toe end of my my um
my using i feel like i'm at the toe-in
but
what is what is going to be the am
is something horrific i've always said
like am i going to have to go through
something so horrific
that i have i'm forced into being clean
or am i going to make that decision to
walk away
because even if i walk away what have
you seen people follow me
no matter where i go even clean
what if i could never get away from
these same men
but this one city that keeps following
me
this family i don't understand the
correlation with all of it
but it's the same people
these same certain individuals that will
not leave me the [ __ ] alone
and i wonder i don't i don't
i can't i try to figure it out and it
just makes me sick and it makes me more
um just makes me more mad
and when baby daddy would lose it um
around i asked him for shoes because i
had no shoes he says
i'm afraid to come around you he didn't
even know he knew i was around because
people have been telling him
so whoever's in his area is warning him
that i've been in the area
you know so i don't know it's just a lot
and it feels
complicated and i don't i don't know i'm
sorry
how are you supporting yourself no um
i'm not hustling like i i was before i
mean
before i was making i wouldn't call
decent money but
enough to support my habit in a room
get food maybe an outfit no
um today i have this guy tried to offer
me five dollars and i walked out of his
car i said
you've got me [ __ ] up i'm not doing
nothing for five dollars
you know yeah like i'm not how i used to
look i'm not as pretty as i used to be
but i still have enough value in me
knowing that i'm worth more than
five dollars
you know i know i have i know i have
worth i know
that there's so much more to me than
what i give myself credit for
i just don't know how to get back to
that how i was before
is going back to your family an option
no no
my um if i was to move back at home that
would never be an option because
me my mom my mom is a very strong
filipino woman
she believes what she believes and i
don't like to listen i like to do
what jillian likes to do and i don't
follow my mom's roles and because i
choose not to follow my mom's rules
i can't live there and i always relapse
i always use when i live in our house
regardless how good i have it i can have
everything working out like life's good
my friends are back in my life
everything's back i will still find a
way to self sabotage
my life i go back to a life that
i'm not meant for that i can't handle
because the drugs handle me
what do you feel like was the biggest
mistake that you've made in your are
in my life um
my biggest mistake um
i would there was say never this is
quite a few
um i would say my biggest mistake was um
leaving my ex-husband and abandoning my
daughters
my life dramatically changed the moment
i walked out on my kids
um i had a good and like my ex-husband
worked he didn't want me to work he
wanted me to be home with my children
take care of the house take care of the
children make sure the kids get off to
school the house is immaculate
you know let him do his thing and i i
did all those things
and i walked away from it because it
still didn't make me happy
and i'm not one of those females that
chooses to stay in a relationship
just because there's kids involved yeah
that's the right thing to do maybe
but i don't believe in giving up my
happiness just because there's children
involved
and i see so many people do that they
give up
a chance that true happiness a true
chance at love
because they got someone pregnant
because
they want to do the right thing
that's just i believe but that was
probably my biggest mistake was leaving
my daughters
because now my oldest is um she's
diagnosed with clinical depression
she has suicidal ideation she blames
herself for being leaving
she believes she's a bad daughter um
and i explained to her that moani's sick
mommy needs help
bad things have happened to mommy to
where she believes that
because she was abused at that certain
age that she my daughters are getting
abused too
no matter how many people could tell me
you're wrong you're wrong you're wrong
but because psychologically of what i've
been through
i believe it's going to happen to my
children
and it continues on for another
generation yeah
yeah but i know it because what happened
to me
won't doesn't automatically mean it's
going to happen
to my daughters or my daughters are not
going to go down the path that i've gone
or
or go you know use drugs just because
i don't know not um
old habits don't always repeat
oh somebody's got to break the cycle
yeah yeah
all right julian well thank you for
talking with me coming back again
i hope you figure something out and turn
your life around because this is you
know it's a dead end right
yeah you see that
all right thank you thank you
you